what's the solution okay brighter side
is what i want to do let's spend the
last 21 minutes talking about the
brighter side
so a few things some people are
listening to this they're from
california oh my gosh what do i do
whatever you're doing don't do anything
emotionally right now like you don't
need to do anything next 30 60 90 days
just kick it we're just having this
conversation because it just happened
that's information yeah so you just need
to have the information you don't need
to emotionally want to all of a sudden
say oh here's what we're doing no
my suggestion number one start
researching
non-stop whatever you can get your hands
on to read research and by the way
any time we're having a podcast and
we're having an issue that we're gonna
debate on the podcast i try to watch two
channels i'll go to msnbc cnn then i'll
go to fox on the same point i'll hear
what tucker has to say then i'll hear
what the left has to say whether it's
joe whether it's
you know maddow you know cooper
i just want to see what's being said on
both sides do your research don't just
do research from one side you will be
fooled i'm telling you right now you
will be fooled if you just get your
information from one side okay so that's
that second part
if you're in a state you know this whole
story about
uh you put a frog in the water you start
boiling it gradually he's not gonna jump
out and then all of a sudden he's like
it's too late it's 212 degrees you're
dead oh i died done right yeah well
that's kind of what's happening in
california it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal
andy grove i'm gonna keep saying this
and people say pat i don't think that's
the right way to live how are you gonna
live a happy life like that
he has the best book he wrote on
business that every c-suite executive
founder entrepreneur needs to leave only
the paranoid survive if you're listening
to this and you're not in a state called
california or new york or oregon or
whatever else you want to call it
and you're in a place like texas or
florida like oh thank god i live in
florida do not be naive are they coming
for you boy do not be naive
this is the war of getting people to
think in a certain way and they are not
slowing down they're going to come after
you the other day i was watching a video
of a mother on david harris's instagram
page this mother was sharing textbooks
of his kids reading these books at 12
years old and i don't know if you saw
that or not did you see that i don't
even want to say it i don't want to say
what we're saying today the mayor i
think because of david harris to show
you the power of information yeah
because of david harris in his reach and
you shared it and a bunch of other
influential people shared it the mayor
went to the town hall called the judge
and said i've confirmed with the judge
that this is child pornography you will
be arrested and you can either resign
your board your board right now
so
this is again not to panic that's that's
what i'm saying
what i'm trying to say is stay paranoid
don't just sit there and say go along
tonight and say babe thank god we're
living in a place like this nope that's
not how i'm wired i still ask the
questions you still got to ask the
question whatever your kids are going to
ask the question what do they talk about
in school today what i talk about in
school today all of a sudden your kid
brings an argument home to you who
brought that up to you my teacher what
did they say they said the president is
this they say that white people are this
they said that you know rich people are
this who said that what makes you
believe that go to school talk to the
teacher about it don't sit around and
say it's not a big deal babe just let it
go it's not a big deal yet let it go how
many times have you heard the story of a
father saying you know my chest hurts
you know my chest hurts you know my
chest hurts it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal six months later it's a big
deal has a heart attack the man dies
your chest was hurting go to the
flipping doctor you could have prevented
that with a blood thinner you could have
lived 30 more years but we lost you we
don't get those memories for you to go
walk your daughter down the aisle stop
acting as if it cannot happen to you
everything is about you not being naive
thinking this cannot happen to your
county to your city to your community to
your state
you have to stay as
active as possible in gathering
information read as much as you can both
sides don't be naive if you do that part
you'll have the highest shot and by the
way i'll say i'll go a little bit even
further than that here's what i will
tell you
um
gary kasparov is at the event two weeks
ago yep okay
and i'm talking to gary and i said gary
you called that putin in 2008.
do you have any political aspirations no
no no i don't want to do any politics i
don't want to go into politics so what
are you talking about do you remember
when i'm like what are you talking about
backstage yeah what do you think
part of this was on stage he says i
tweet i said what do you mean you're not
going to go wrong for politics no no i
don't want to go to po i said no you got
to go
you got to do something you can't just
be sitting here writing stuff you have a
story that you can actu look at what
david harris is doing with his stuff he
flips there are people that are flipping
today even jpc is the comedian he's
getting people to think because the
approach is taken the guy is very
important today jp sears is very
necessary today who's the most necessary
person in america today who's the most
necessary who is and named the number
one most necessary person in america
today dave chappelle it's it's a guy
named joe rogan rogan there isn't
anybody in america today most necessary
than joe rogan joe has got the same
status thank god they still haven't come
after him to say he's done something
they've tried i understand but he's got
such a loyal following that the people
will go after them
so some people who have never had any
aspirations
for politics i think it's time yeah some
people have never had any desires to
want to go do anything and you kind of
seen some of the stuff that's really
brewing in you and it's firing you up do
not waste that fire
do something with it yeah it may be a
five-year plan and maybe a 10-year plan
it may be a 15-year plan or maybe a
20-year plan but it's time to get the
bench deep
because the next 10 20 30 40 years we're
going to need some true solid true
believers
real quick because uh sorry but to his
point i have the perfect example that
when i was working in the state house in
jersey there was a nun all right and it
does you don't have to run the whole
point of reason i'm saying this is that
he's so right you don't have to run you
don't even have to donate you just have
to be loud there was a nun who said
their people were drag racing down the
block okay down the block she called the
state house every single day when can we
get a speed bump okay i'll call back
tomorrow when can we get a speed bump
one woman
one woman all right she called for like
32 straight days and then finally my
boss jean ashmore was like my god
almighty somebody just gave this lady a
freaking speedboat she got the speed
bump yeah she got the speed bump that
one lady making a phone call every day
she spoke for an entire community and
got it done and i'll validate one other
thing that pat said that if you think
you live in south dakota texas florida
idaho one of these states where you
think you're safe they're coming for
your school oh my god all right they're
infiltrating the core of the apple right
so they can get these kids now and
they're patient so don't think it's not
happening in your state and in your
state
you were in dallas go to deep alum did
it feel like you were in when did it
feel like you were in texas no red tech
no go to houston did it feel like you
were in red texas interviewed a lot of
people ebor city in florida eblor city
could be brooklyn new york so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you